the white house is getting called out on
shocking allegations of child
sex abuse at a migrant center in texas
and the governor of the state of texas
is pushing for a federal investigation
i'm harris faulkner and you
are in the faulkner focus governor greg
abbott says the white house
has to close a san antonio facility
abbott says he is receiving tips that
migrant children
were sexually assaulted there and there
is insufficient
food at the facility among other
allegations
of abuse governor abbott says president
biden's policies
are fueling this horror
these problems are a byproduct of
president biden's
open border policies this facility
is a health and safety nightmare
the body administration is now presiding
over the abuse
of children to end this abuse
the biden administration must
immediately
shut down this facility
and then there's this an arizona border
chief has released this stunning photo
showing more than 130 migrants
apprehended at the border as the surge
shows no signs
of slowing down in focus now arizona
attorney general
mark brnovich attorney general thank you
for being on the program
harrison thank you for having me here
i i want to start off with what you need
to do
next in the state of texas because when
you hear the governor
you two work in concert i would imagine
together you're the legal arm of that
what needs to be communicated how is it
being communicated to the white house
well i think the governor of texas has
done a
no no but the governor of texas has done
a great job and i think that um
he's actually trying to do something and
you know there's kind of a running joke
that when
governor abbott does something some of
the other governors will at least say
the right thing a week later and so
i think it's important i can only
control what i can do as you know harris
i have multiple lawsuits right now
we have a hearing today in federal court
trying to reinstitute the deportation
policy there's
1.2 million people here that are
scheduled for deportation
by the administration halted that we
know that the biden administration has
incentivized
people coming here by getting rid of the
public charge rule we want to make sure
that
that is defendant that's in place so
people aren't getting you know
child care and medicare and other public
health benefits the taxpayers paid for
but i think it's important to draw
attention to these issues because what
is happening on the border
is a crisis right now but it is about to
become a preventable tragedy
this is something the abide
administration set in motion with all of
their various policies
um they've eliminated the remaining
mexico policy so
they've encouraged people to come here
they've incentivized it they're
decriminalizing it
and we know that there's actually
criminal gang members and even middle
eastern terrorists coming into our
country
yeah and there are facts with that now i
mean this is not just a
you know a point of opinion that someone
thought that they could debate at one
point from the administration there are
numbers and
video and pictures speaking of which new
numbers from the hhs and dhs
now attorney general brnovich are
showing an
eye-popping 20 000 plus child migrants
in federal custody
and nearly 19 000 unaccompanied children
were encountered
on the border in just march that's a 100
percent increase from february
and the biden administration officials
now report that 172 000 people
in total attempted to cross the border
in march and that's a 7 100
or a 71 percent increase from february
most of them
single adults tell me what is happening
to let that let those numbers increase
so quick
so quickly well the biden administration
has essentially
signaled an open door and you know you
mentioned
you know the politics and everything
else going on this i keep telling folks
this isn't an issue of right versus
left it's an issue of right versus wrong
and this may be in our front yard today
but it'll be in everyone's backyard
tomorrow and you mentioned that number
of 174 thousand
just to put that in context i mean
that's the entire population of a city
like
tempe that you know hosts the fiesta
bowl um every year it's the size of
syracuse
bigger than syracuse new york so we are
seeing the system overwhelmed
and we know that along with people that
are on the terrorist watches that have
come in
i know that there's also folks from
other middle eastern countries that have
come in
and um it is unsustainable and
indeed there will be a tragedy at some
point i mean just look at the basic
numbers i know in
pinellas county the sheriff we have a
hearing today and he's got
an affidavit a declaration in the
hearing that
more than 50 percent of the people that
they have in custody now
are recidivists they are people that
have been charged with crimes like
assault and robbery
um felony drug charges um that are being
apprehended
so you know it's not just folks coming
here trying to find work there are
criminals and dangerous people coming
into our country
and this is going to affect us for
generations if we don't stop this right
now
well you know it's been two weeks since
vice president kamala harris was tapped
to oversee the situation that's
happening at the border
but the vice president has yet to hold a
briefing or pay a visit to the border
the white house is getting defensive
when asked about
harris's other recent trips including a
bakery in chicago
on tuesday let's watch and i'll get your
response
the vice president was visiting chicago
actually to talk about
covid and the importance of communities
getting the vaccine when it's available
and accessible to them
and so while she was there like many
americans she got a snack
i think she's allowed to do that all
right before we go with you
let's hear from you and ambassador nikki
haley who unleashed
on the vice president kamala harris
um apparently she's the one in charge
this is the same person that encouraged
7 000 migrants to come to america
she referred to ice as the kkk she's now
in charge of this she's been missing in
action and god help us if she ever
becomes president because if this house
she handles in my uh
crisis i mean i just can't imagine how
she would run our country
attorney general your reaction well i
guess marie antoinette wanted folks to
eat cake
and the vice president wants to have a
snack i will tell you
that i've invited the vice president to
come down here you know she was a former
state agent while i was agi
you know we're both child children of
immigrants
she believes very strongly in trying to
prevent human trafficking and we know
that the cartels are exploiting people
they make money
off every single person that crosses
harris so i invite once again the vice
president to come down here
meet with law enforcement myself let's
talk about this
let's actually try to address this issue
instead of doing washington dc does
every time
which is kick the can down the road we
can't do that
well and and what you pointed out as you
know we were going back and forth
between texas and arizona
this is happening along the border she
was in california where there actually
was a wall
and and that would be the argument for
the wall i suppose since she lived there
and they certainly didn't tear it down
but now you get to see those areas that
are more porous without
that fence line and i would imagine you
want to see that
you know if you're going to adjudicate
anything about it let's move to this
a suspected ms-13 gang member was
arrested in california after authorities
say
he illegally crossed the border into the
united states
this comes after two suspected yemeni
terrorists were apprehended at the
border in just the past
few months you alluded to that attorney
general house minority leader kevin
mccarthy
confirming he was requested a classified
briefing
from the feds on the security threat
your reaction
this is a national security threat once
again regardless of what people think
about the border issue
everyone needs to appreciate this isn't
about border security it's about
national security
there are people literally on the
terrorist watch list trying to get into
this country
there are people that have gotten into
this country on the terrorist watch list
and there are people from assorted
middle eastern countries
that have been apprehended as i alluded
to earlier the sheriff in panel county
has told us that more than half the
people
are recidivists that have been charged
with dangerous crimes so you have not
only this terrorist threat
you have literally thousands of people
with criminal records that are coming
into the country right now
and we know we know from what's going on
on the border sometimes you'll get a
rush of migrants like 100 people
border patrol has to go there they have
to apprehend them they have to process
them
while they're doing it the cartels are
literally driving trucks across the
border where there's no wall
so you know once again this joe biden
has created this by
decriminalizing and incentivizing it and
i just i keep thinking about
you know what uh william shakespeare
billy shakespeare wrote 500 years ago
the fault dear brutus not lies in
ourselves not in the stars
joe biden created this problem and the
white house has to solve this problem
right now
or else someone is going to really get
hurt and there's going to be a terrible
tragedy in this country
well look when the attorney general of
arizona invites you to come to the
border that's not like a light
afternoon out for lunch i want to know
when she responds
or her team responds and you guys get
ready to make that happen let's see if
it will
because that's a fun i will buy her a
pastry i will buy her a pastry if that
will encourage her to come here
all right attorney general brnovich of
arizona thank you for being with me
thank you hair so much